do you want me  would you also like to meet this guy and  this guy and this guy well here's the  deal U.S midterm elections are in  November and if you can vote in them but  don't know how and aren't planning on  figuring it out well I don't want to see  you but if you go to headcount.org  Vsauce and register to vote or just  simply check your voter registration  status you will be entered to win a trip  for two to Los Angeles to hang out with  me here at Vsauce headquarters and tour  the LA Natural History Museum together  now voter registration deadlines are  coming up soon in your state so do not  wait do it now and one of you will win a  chance to hang out with me we can chat  we can share a laugh  if you want to we can even hug  please